Push & Line s web japan to do 6
Ugetsu Perform Shitsu Seal Blue Do Camp Bar
Wine Voice
[Applause]
Filter Paper Zario Late Leakage Yoshida Detection
Playing a huge front line
Yufir version Messer Sato Share
aqua feel good for a 6 bd to do
Fishing net boats came from China about 500 years ago, 600 years ago.
Blog Gamering Inc. Myriad Edges s 5 users
face t + df Pablo Laversion Ashe girls are you
doing
This tourer's gaze is fierce
and thin, the Japanese jazz style  It's called 6 selections of Gore method 2. It
's an instrument that requires real practice.
Ramp 4 dn duplex
forever
So what kind of gap is being created between the part where I've gained strength and what I'm doing
?  It's not about quitting, it's about
giving
the audience a chance to see the various possibilities of the shamisen while embodying the question of what kind of music only the Yoshida brothers can
do.
[Applause]
[Music]